mes chers amis on va pas se refaire moi
j'aime bien les images
alors je vous ai préparé petit
accompagnement en images voilà la
situation du 23 avril 2010 cette
situation politique
vous voyez les résultats le ps 6,4 pour
cent et ainsi emmanuel macron réalisé
son premier rêve éradiquer le ps mais il
nous l'a dit face caméra dans des
documentaires son deuxième objectif
c'est d'éradiquer la droite bien sûr
c'est confortable de se maintenir au
pouvoir
entre jean luc mélenchon et marine le
pen jean-luc mélenchon le crypto
marxistes qui fait l'apologie de fidel
castro et de cuba qu'il puise son
inspiration venezuela dans l'alliance
bolivarienne
et puis la famille le pen qui rêvent de
transformer la france en un petit
village gaulois avec des petites
barrières autour isolé par rapport au
monde
alors on entend beaucoup de gens nous
expliquer qu'on aurait des atomes
crochus avec le front national qu'on
aurait une proximité avec le front
national
mais quand on regarde de près le front
national il a surtout une proximité avec
la france insoumise c'est exactement
c'est exactement le même projet
économique la retraite à 60 ans le
maintien des 35 heures
et puis évidemment on laisse filer la
dépense publique à qui ira le plus loin
145 milliards pour madame le pen 200
milliards pour monsieur mélenchon voilà
le discours populiste sur lequel ils
sont d'accord et ils ont un autre point
d'accord qui est tellement loin du nôtre
c'est qu'ils veulent
l'un comme l'autre sortir de l'europe
alors évidemment nous avons besoin de
dire stop à ce scénario catastrophe se
retrouver à devoir choisir entre
mélenchon et le pen
rappelez vous mes chers amis ni combien
avons nous été en france en 2010 est à
avoir peur de devoir choisir entre
mélenchon et le pen entre la peste et le
choléra
alors oui la droite doit se reconstruire
et c'est pour ça aujourd'hui que nous
sommes réunis
alors pour se reconstruire elle a besoin
d'un leader elle a besoin d'un leader
incontesté cent mille militants ont voté
74% des suffrages se sont portés sur
notre président est ce président c'est
lanvaux quai
alors laurent il amène son énergie sa
détermination sa volonté sa compétence
et puis il a voulu s'entourer d'une
équipe une équipe de renouvellement ils
sont tous ici présents une équipe jeune
une équipe paritaire une équipe plus
réel une équipe avec toutes les
sensibilités
une équipe qui est fière de porter
derrière laurent cette reconstruction de
la droite
[Applaudissements]
alors cher laurent je veux te remercier
de ta confiance
je veux vous remercier tous de votre
confiance apportée à annie et à moi ce
matin ici même et puis je veux vous dire
que moi j'ai toujours voté à droite j'ai
jamais changé de conviction je viens de
l'entreprise j'ai passé plus de 20 ans
je suis profondément libérale et je
crois à une droite qui rassemble toutes
les sensibilités
et puis on a la chance d'avoir aussi des
talents et des talents complémentaires
jean leonetti le président de notre
conseil national eric ciotti le
président de notre commission nationale
d'investiture
et bernard acoyer le président du comité
d'études politiques
nous avons aussi la chance de pouvoir
nous appuyer sur des personnes de
sagesse et d'expérience je pense bien
sûr au président du sénat gérard larcher
ici présents et à bruno retailleau
président du groupe au sénat
et je pense bien sûr à christian jacob
le président du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale
et laurent tu viens de nous le dire tu a
souhaité tendre la main à tous et c'est
pour ça que tu as accepté d'avoir des
mouvements associés à notre parti et
valérie vient de présenter la création
de libre et je n'oublie pas nos amis
chasseurs cher eddie puyjalon que j'ai
croisés et qui est parmi nous alors mes
chers amis bien sûr que nous ne sommes
pas toujours d'accord sur tout jean
leonetti l'a si bien exprimé bien sûr
que julien guillaume vous êtes contrôle
settat et que damien au mois on est pour
mais ce que je sais c'est qu'on se
retrouvera toujours pour défendre les
classes populaires
bien sûr valérie ou madeleine sont plus
conservatrices sur le plan sociétal que
geoffroy par exemple ou moi mais on se
retrouvera toujours pour défendre les
chrétiens d'orient par exemple alors
alors moi je crois à la richesse de ce
débat je crois au respect entre les
individus
cette équipe elle fonctionne bien elle
s'entend bien
elle a un chef il tranchera quand il y
aura besoin de trancher mais moi je vous
le dis on sera capable de se mettre
d'accord parce que notre socle de
valeurs c'est ce qui nous unit et ce
socle de valeurs personne peut nous le
prendre c'est notre fond de moi c'est
notre ciment et c'est ça la force de
notre parti
[Applaudissements]
alors beaucoup parient sur nos divisions
beaucoup même l'espère puisque c'est le
scénario bien déclaré visant à essayer
de faire exploser la droite on n'a pas
envie de tomber dans ce piège grossier
de l'explosion de la droite et des
divisions est pourquoi ne réussirions
nous pas ce que d'autres avant nous ont
réussi et je veux saluer monsieur le
premier ministre edouard balladur qui
est ici au premier rang
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre sur ces
photos vous êtes entouré de jacques
chirac et d'alain madelin on retrouve
charles pasqua ou philippe séguin on
retrouve françois fillon ou alain juppé
et bien évidemment on retrouve nicolas
sarkozy
et je n'oublierai pas celle qui était
tout jeune qui nous a précédés à toutes
ces femmes qui sont ici et qui sont
fiers de la parité aujourd'hui mais il
ya eu des femmes de combat et qui était
bien seul sur la photo et je veux saluer
michèle alliot marie
alors mes chers amis finalement rien n'a
changé hormis la parité cher michel rien
n'a changé les gaullistes sociaux les
libéraux les conservateurs la droite
forte la droite humaniste comme tu le
disais si bien laurent ya pas de droite
molle de droite dure il ya une seule
droite et c'est la nôtre
alors on nous fait le procès parfois des
trains proximité avec le front national
ce qui est une aberration
mais on nous fait aussi souvent ce cette
déclaration qui emmanuel macron mènerait
une politique de droite
certains même dans nos rangs on se dira
qu emmanuel macron ferai ce que nous
aurions rêvé de faire
et bien non mes chers amis je ne le
crois pas parce que si on regarde le
budget 2010 8 qu'est ce qu'on constate
une augmentation des dépenses de l'état
de 6 4 milliards d'euros
là les impôts 2018 qui augmentent de 4,5
milliards d'euros et en l'espace de
quelques mois le nouveau gouvernement a
réussi à créer pas moins de huit ans de
huit taxes supplémentaires
bref comme toujours la créativité
technocratique n'a pas de limites
pendant ce temps le pouvoir d'achat lui
va baisser de 8% pour 9 millions de
retraités à cause de la hausse de la csg
les titres de séjour les titres de
séjour augmentent de 14% par rapport à
l'année précédente et la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation
n'étant ni n'est qu'un petit bonneteau
fiscale puisque on réduit pas à la
dépense publique qui va simplement
permettre au gouvernement de centraliser
encore davantage le jacobinisme est de
retour alors mes chers amis non nous ne
voulons non emmanuel macron ne fait pas
la politique que nous voulions et non
nous avons clairement décidé de
présenter un autre projet pour les
français
mais laurent wauquiez le détaillera plus
longuement dans un instant je vous ai
simplement préparer entre nous pour
s'amuser un peu
un petit quizz qui résume les vrais
défis qui sont devant nous et que nous
allons devoir relever ensemble
savez vous ce que représente 36 mille
euros trente six mille euros c'est le
poids de la dette pour chaque nouveau né
en france sur ses épaules
trois millions quatre cent cinquante et
un mille c le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi en catégorie a qui est resté
stable alors que nous avons une
croissance de 9%
nous sommes les parents pauvres de
l'europe en matière de chômage 22,6 pour
cent c'est un taux qui nous fait froid
dans le dos parce que c'est le taux de
chômage des jeunes c'est un taux qui a
augmenté
là encore de ne de 0 9% en six mois
c'est ça les résultats du gouvernement
c'est ça la promesse de mettre nos
jeunes au travail voilà les sujets dont
la droite va devoir s'emparer pour
proposer une autre voie
[Applaudissements]
le 29 juillet mes chers amis vous savez
ce que c'est le 29 juillet c'est la date
à laquelle vous commencez à travailler
pour vous parce que jusque là vous avez
travaillé pour l'état
alors oui il faut réduire la dépense
publique et oui c'est une priorité
absolue
et quand on entend le gouvernement
actuel qui ne baisse pas d'un iota la
dépense publique
qu'on ne vienne pas nous dire qu'il mène
une politique de droite
il mène la politique socialiste dont ce
pays a trop souffert 262000 ça vous
savez ce que c'est c'est le nombre de
titres de séjour qui ont été délivrés
l'année dernière un record comme tu l'as
dit cher laurent jeudi dans cette très
brillante émission un record depuis 40
ans bien sûr que notre pays doit
s'enorgueillir de pouvoir être une terre
d'asile pour des réfugiés politiques en
grande détresse
mais il est temps de réguler notre
immigration et ça c'est malheureusement
à des défis importants du 21e siècle
défi migratoire est devant nous et le
gouvernement ferme les yeux pour ne pas
traiter un problème majeur pour notre
pays
[Applaudissements]
et 15000 dernier petit chiffre que je
voulais partager avec vous c'est le
nombre de fichiers s sur notre
territoire
là encore nous avons un énorme défi et
c'est pas en mettant la tête dans le
sable ou enfants nous diabolisant dès
que nous osons parler des vrais
problèmes des français que
malheureusement nous réd nous réussirons
à résoudre ces problèmes
alors oui la droite a besoin d'un
programme fort oui la droite à paarl
besoin de parler vrai tu le dit laurent
et tu le fais tu as des résultats dans
ta région je viens de l'entreprise je
suis attaché au faire je suis attaché au
concret et je crois que laurent wauquiez
a prouvé en auvergne rhône-alpes qu'il
était capable de faire pour la france ce
qu'il fait aujourd'hui pour rhône alpes
auvergne en baissant massivement la
dépense publique et en répondant aux
attentes des citoyens
alors mes chers amis ce que nous allons
faire tous ensemble parce que derrière
laurent wauquiez parce que derrière les
personnalités que j'ai cités parce que
derrière l'équipe qui est ici sur scène
il y à une équipe bien plus grande et
c'est vous voulez conseillers nationaux
vous les militants voulaient fédération
sur tout le territoire de la france qui
allait nous aider à rentrer dans cette
phase merveilleuse est formidable de la
reconstruction
alors mes chers amis c'est sûr que ça va
être long on a une bonne année déjà
devant nous et ça va être l'enjeu de
celui de la reconstruction mais ont
voulu promet on est tous ici réunis pour
que 2019 et 2020 ce soit les années de
la reconquête pour les les européennes
et pour les municipales vive la
république vive les républicains
[Applaudissements]